[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
largué à 12000 mètres l'avion fusée
américain x15 qu'on appelle déjà
l'escaladeur des espaces où il égratigne
heures des toiles a effectué un nouvel
essai avec des moteurs 4 fois supérieure
aux anciens c'est dire qu'il sera
capable d'atteindre la vitesse
incroyable de 6500 kilomètres à l'heure
et l'altitude non moins incroyable de
200 mm x 15 le premier avion piloté
capable d'accomplir un vol spatial
c'est un autre succès que celui de la
récupération un vol de la capsule du
disco vers r17 premier d'une série de
satellites d'observation capable de
changer d'orbité la capsule plaqué or
lourde de 133 kg contient une série
d'instruments secrets dont les rapports
doivent servir au perfectionnement des
satellites d'observation samos et midas
l'avant-garde des espions céleste
[Musique]
on joue les a toujours
le sous marin atomique george washington
a reçu sa charge de cette fusée polaris
à ogive thermonucléaire avant de quitter
sa base de charleston pour sa première
patrouille opérationnel quelque part
dans l'atlantique
ces fusées peuvent être lancées du
sous-marin en plongée elles ont une
portée de 2000 km le george washington
devient ainsi le premier submersible
atomique américain capable d'entrer
immédiatement en action
[Musique]
dans un domaine plus modestes bien
entendu la base française de biscarrosse
a mis en action des fusées cible destiné
à la mise au point et à l'entraînement
des armes anti aériennes
ces engins sont des avions
radiocommandés à pulse au réacteur
émaner des modèles mise au point par les
allemands à la base de pinot min sous le
nom de v1 et v2
les radars suivre la course des engins
qui seront ensuite repêché au large
fusée satellites avions spatiaux la
course à l'espace continue
au bureau une improvisation pour
atteindre un dossier et c'est la chute
un simple escabeau pour les classeurs
élevé constitue le minimum d'une
organisation tant soit peu rationnelle
à l' usine l'absence d'un garde-corps
auprès d'une fausse chutent chutent
encore plus grave lorsqu'il s'agit
d'acide sulfurique
[Musique]
l'absence de fixation d'une échelle et
c'est un autre risque de chute
on ne saurait trop insister sur
l'importance des précautions à prendre
comme par exemple de fixer une échelle
avant de s'en servir aussi bien aux
sommets d'ailleurs copier car ce sont
chaque année cent mille accidents du
travail qui sont dues aux chutes de
hauteur chute dont les conséquences sont
presque toujours graves et peuvent être
très graves
[Musique]
c'est évidemment au niveau le plus élevé
si l'on peut dire c'est à dire sur les
toits qu'il convient d'être le plus
exigeant ici l'usagé de la ceinture de
sécurité devrait être automatique
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un travail de plus
longue durée l'édification d'un
échafaudage contenta systèmes complets
de protection s'impose isolé du vide les
ouvriers peuvent ainsi évoluer de plain
pied sans risque même à 20 mètres du sol
[Musique]
venant après l'opération artichauts
l'opération chou-fleur a eu son plein
succès plusieurs jours de suite des
convois de camions ont apporté en plein
paris les choux-fleurs de bretagne vendu
au tiers des prix couramment pratiqué
bonne affaire pour les ménagères qui
attendent maintenant les commandos de
pommes de terre carottes oignons et même
de vin que se sont promis de conduire du
producteur au consommateur les
cultivateurs et les vignerons
[Musique]
c'est à mulhouse cette année que se sont
réunis les urbanistes du monde entier
immense rassemblement spirituel qui
énonce des idées soumet des solutions et
contrôle des expériences dans ce domaine
important qui est devenu l'un des
premiers dans notre monde puisqu'il
touche à l'un des besoins essentiels de
l'homme vivre en société
mulhouse et sa région ont été choisis
comme un exemple probant en matière de
rénovation urbaine et de remise en ordre
de la cité un exemple à suivre
dans ce domaine de la remise en ordre de
la cité notons avec plaisir la
démolition en cours des bâtiments
provisoires ajouté au palais de chaillot
en 51 pour quelques mois et qui ont duré
neuf ans l'onu les occupants puis le
temps aujourd'hui tout est à vendre en
pièces détachées porte fenêtre cloisons
dans les derniers gravats auront disparu
les jardins du trocadéro réapparaîtront
enfin dirons nous
[Musique]
c'est un règne de près de 30 ans sur
tous les écrans du monde que vient de
mettre fin la mort subite de clark gable
une crise cardiaque a terrassé à l'âge
de 59 ans celui que l'on appelait le roi
de relier
[Musique]
clark gable avait été aussi le major
games la dernière guerre l'avait vu
gagner ses galons comme apprenti
canonnier puis dans une unité de l'armée
de l'air
image fugitive du soldat qui s'efface
devant celle de la vedette aux 90 films
1939 avec à ses côtés carole lombard sa
troisième épouse disparue depuis dans un
accident d'avion
clark gable pouvait prendre la mesure de
sa popularité à l'occasion de la
première d'autant en emporte le vent
[Musique]
aujourd'hui valérie qui pourtant dit on
n'a pas le coeur tendre pleure son héros
préféré
et avec hollywood des millions de
spectateurs
[Musique]
c'est un en blouse blanche ce n'est pas
un dactylographe c'est le typographe des
temps futurs qui commence aujourd'hui
dans cette imprimerie parisienne est
révolutionnaire et gutenberg seraient à
juste titre étonné par ces machines
électro mécaniques et électroniques
qu'on appelle les limites type appelé à
faire table rase de l'arsenal classique
des linotype et du ladder l'élément
principal de cette machinerie est un
disque de 20 cm de diamètre percé de
trous représentant 14 série de
caractères différents
à lui seul ce disque d'un kilo accompli
le travail de 168 série de matrix
classique qui exigerait deux tonnes de
cui voici comment en tapant simplement
l'article le typo désigne les lettres à
reproduire en même temps qu'il choisit
la série de caractère et leur grosseur
ayant enregistré tous ces renseignements
la calculatrice électronique prend le
relais elle décide de la rotation du
disque et choisit l'un des douze
objectifs aussi sans qu'ils fixeront
l'oeil du caractère voulue par le
compositeur à chaque position correspond
en chambre noire
la projection sur film transparent de la
lettre correspondant cas dans ce deal
être projeté à la seconde
l'article terminé il suffira d'aller
développer la pellicule impressionné
il ne restera plus en cinq à passer du
positif ainsi obtenu à l'héliogravure
traditionnelle après la mise en page
précisons que si cette machine
révolutionnaire et de construction
américaines
elle a été conçue par deux français
higonnet et moi roues et il suffit d'une
comparaison pour juger de la qualité du
résultat de castagnède à passer ce grèce
supporter numéro 1 de l'équipe de
football de monaco espérait bien
assister et ils ont eu raison à la
seconde défaite du racing club de paris
cette saison
ne nous laissons pas abuser par cette
attaque du racing culotte noire il n'y
en aura pas beaucoup d'autres cours de
la partie
c'est monaco au contraire qui fait la
démonstration de ce qu'est le football
direct et efficace auquel le passé la
princesse penta gros tapis et voilà
comment cossou le monégasque marque le
premier but
[Applaudissements]
voilà également comment le mièvre du
racing échoue devant les défenseurs
monégasques le jeu en profondeur est
toujours payant les joueurs du racing
ont du plomb sous leur semaine ils sont
pris de vitesse à chaque instant 2 0
c'est le score à la mi temps et ce n'est
pas cher à définir
[Applaudissements]
la princesse grace et passionnée par ce
spectacle enthousiasmant il faut bien
l'avouer
pourquoi s'arrêter en si bon chemin un
troisième but fort légitime consacre la
victoire de monaco sion le racing
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]